so with the new it movie coming out in
just a couple days I figured I better do
that video I promised where I answer
your questions cinder is out of town
right now so it's just gonna be me
answering the questions but I'm feeling
pretty confident that I can give you
guys a satisfying answer the first
question comes from Chloe Froude she
asks do you think it will take the shape
of other forms that weren't seen in the
miniseries such as jaws that's a good
question Chloe yes I do think that we'll
see it take other forms but I'm not so
sure about jaws I talked about this a
little bit in my ideas for it at
Halloween Horror Nights check that video
out here if you haven't seen it and
basically what I said is that in the
book and the miniseries which take place
in the 50s it takes the form of some of
the movie monsters from back then the
most notable one being Ritchie having an
encounter with the Wolfman after going
to see the Wolfman film in theaters and
being afraid of it because it is
constantly preying on the fears of its
victims so my idea was that instead of
using classic 50s horror icons is that
this movie would use classic 80s horror
icons like Freddy Jason Chucky and
Michael Myers so to answer the part of
your question about Jaws I doubt that
we'll see jaws in this movie because
that movie came out in 1975 so it would
be more applicable to if this movie was
taking place in the 70s as opposed to
the 80s yes it was still relevant in the
80s but I just don't see a spot for jaws
to really appear in derry the only major
body of water is the can dusky extreme
and I think it would be a little bit
silly for a shark to appear out of a
stream it could happen but I think it's
more likely that we'll see horror icons
from the 80s in this film next question
comes from Angelo zu Rolla are all
appending wises red balloons the dead
children that he's eaten well if you
look at it in a literal sense no there
is a separate physical manifestation of
the dead children which appears at the
end of the story which I'm not going to
spoil right now for those who haven't
seen the movie but in a more symbolic
sense I would say yes they do represent
the dead children which is why Pennywise
is always using the line you'll float
too or you'll float down here because
each of Pennywise is victims does float
again I
give it away and I think the red
balloons are kind of like a physical
manifestation of that in the real world
so yes the balloons do kind of represent
his victims
Gavin Kay asks our next question will
the it movie be in two parts yes it will
so the movie was originally supposed to
come out as it's part one the losers
Club and then at some point they
simplified the title to just it but it
is still going to be a two-parter like
the miniseries was with the child's
portion taking place first and the adult
portion taking place in part two I think
that the main difference between this
movie and the miniseries is that in the
miniseries it kind of sticks to the
formula laid out by the book where it
actually starts with the Lucky seven as
adults being called back to their
hometown to face it again based on the
promise that they made years ago as each
one of them is called back and they
remember what happened to them in dairy
and they have these flashbacks of their
encounters with penny wise as children
so it has kind of a nonlinear story
structure where it takes place in the
present but it has these flashbacks to
their childhood memories in the past and
we see how things unfolded my prediction
is that this new movie is not going to
do that and it's just going to tell the
story in a linear fashion with the
beginning starting at the very beginning
of the child portion and part one
stretching until that promise is made
and then part two will just cover their
lives as adults and not include those
flashbacks to their childhood Maddy
plays asks doesn't it live in the sewers
and that's a response to the video that
I did showing the niebolt house and the
hashtag that's where it lives basically
implying that it lives in Twentynine
niebolt
in the book yes it does live in the
sewers I think the best way for me to
explain this is that the 29 niebolt
house is like its HQ upon the surface
whereas it's true home is down in the
sewers we also see in the trailer and
the it experience itself which if you
want to check out that video here is the
link that 29 niebolt seems to be
connected to the sewers and there's a
scene where they use a projector to line
up the map of the sewers with the map of
Derry and basically show that the sewer
lines run right under the 29 niebolt
house there's a scene in the book where
they actually venture into 29 niebolt
and confront penny wise and penny wise
actually retreats from there down into
the sewers where they eventually go to
have their fun
confrontation with them so I would
expect something similar here neezy
squad asks do you think that this movie
will be better than the TV series or
will it be bad and horrible him of
course referring to the 1990 TV
mini-series starring Tim Curry I have
high hopes for this movie I think with
each trailer that's come out I've gotten
more excited for it I've talked to a
couple people who have seen the film and
heard nothing but positive things so far
so I'm not really expecting a
disappointment do I think it'll be
better than the TV miniseries well I
think there's definitely a chance for it
to be the miniseries in my opinion is
very good I think this movie is going to
do a lot of things that the miniseries
just was not able to I've talked about
this a little bit in things you've
missed but one example is the inclusion
of Patrick Hawk Studdard who I'll just
say is a character who does some
extremely dark things in the book that
couldn't be included in the miniseries
and I've heard that this new movie will
just go to those darker places will go
to those more extreme lengths and this
is one of many examples in the book of
just how dysfunctional this town of
Derry is how all of the adults seem to
be willing to turn a blind eye to the
horrible things that are happening to
these kids and I hope that we can see
more of that in this new movie now will
it live up to what we were given with
the miniseries again I think it'll be
different but I'm hoping with the
increased budget and the r-rating that
it will live up to what we were given in
1990 and maybe even surpass it and
another thing is that part two will be
very interesting because the best part
of the miniseries is the child portion
and there's still a lot of things that I
like about the adult portion the very
ending not really being one of them but
if you ask pretty much anyone what their
favorite part was they're probably gonna
say Part 1 so what I'm most interested
to see is how part two is going to
compare to part two of the miniseries
I'm hoping that they might take it in a
different direction and hopefully
include the thing that happens after the
ending of the miniseries that happens in
the book if you guys have read the book
you know what I'm talking about okay
next we're gonna get into some spoiler
questions so if you haven't read the
book I recommend clicking away or
pausing this video and reading the book
it's a long book mine blocks 20 says I
think they'll have a spot where they
show it as the spider creature what do
you think well I think it's pretty
unlikely that we'll see that in this
film I think if they do decide to go
with the spider again that it will be in
part two so do I think that it will be
in part two yes I think that we'll see
it but I think they may shift away from
that being like the final boss kind of
thing it's something that works a little
bit better on paper but I think it's
just more fitting for the clown that
terrorized them through this entire
thing to be the final boss as opposed to
this spider which kind of comes out of
nowhere I do understand the reasoning
for the spider because the Lucky seven
or what's left of them come together and
it is unable to find something that
they're all afraid of and this is really
like the best form that it can manifest
to face all of them at once but with
that being said you want the end of the
movie to be the climax the scariest part
so I don't think that having a spider is
really the best option and this is also
something that's touched on in the book
I forget who it was but somebody is
thinking that a spider is something that
you might see crawling around in your
kitchen it's something that you
experience in real life whereas killer
clowns are not so that makes it a lot
easier for them to face I would like to
see the spider form come up at some
point and during that confrontation in
part two but I don't think that it
should be the final boss another clue
towards the possible inclusion of the
spider again I've talked about this
before but the Dark Tower movie it may
or may not have tie-ins with this it
movie I know they're made by different
studios but there are a lot of Stephen
King references in The Dark Tower movie
one of which being while they're at an
abandoned amusement park and they're
sitting by the fire talking about the
monsters that live in this outer realm
that surrounds like their central
universe I forget what the exact terms
for at all but you're gonna have to bear
with me on that and so he draws in the
sand he shows like their central
universe and he shows the creatures that
are trying to get in from outside and
the creature that's used as an example
is a tarantula which crawls into the
barrier and comes to where they are so
if the movies are connected that could
be some kind of foreshadowing for the
fact that the spider creature will
appear again Sammy Saul Dana do you know
if Ritchie will die because in the
trailer it showed something like that in
the book and in the miniseries Ritchie
does not die he is one of the survivors
and I can't really see them killing him
off in this one like I said I think the
only two major differences are going to
be
fact that this takes place in the 80s
rather than the 50s and the nonlinear
story structure being shifted into a
more linear one just focusing on the
kids in part one in any event in this
first movie I can't really see any of
the kids dying we even see in the
trailer the scene of the promise and
they all seem to be present for that so
I think everybody at least makes it onto
part two blitzen Ben asks do you think
penny wise will reveal his true form and
there were a lot of questions about this
asking do you think that we'll see the
spider do you think we'll see the true
form and in my mind this is just a
little bit different than the question
about the spider because he could be
referring to the dead lights as penny
wise his true form not the spider and of
course it's gonna depend how you
interpret it but I see the dead lights
as the true form of it whereas penny
wise and the spider are just different
manifestations including some of the
other ones that I talked about so do I
think that the dead lights are gonna be
in this movie we haven't really seen any
evidence of it in the trailer but there
is this one shot of Beverly being lifted
up off of the ground which could also
tie into the phrase you'll float too and
there seems to be like some kind of
light shining on her so I think that
could be the work of the dead lights and
I do think that we'll see the dead
lights make a return in this adaptation
so that's just about covers the
questions you guys asked on Twitter I'm
gonna be seeing this movie as early as
possible and get cooking on hopefully a
new episode of things you missed so be
on the lookout for that remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive